das rote Telefon das in Zeiten des
Kalten Kriegs der heimliche heiße Draht
war zwischen Moskau und Washington da
steht jetzt hier guck mal da an der am
Rand vom Tisch im Kanzleramt ja das ist
ein Foto von Telefonat das Kanzlers mit
Putin und seitdem spricht Deutschland
über dieses Jahr etwas altbacken aus der
rote Telefon wir nennen das schon zuvor
ja das ist nach Bildinformation ein
hochsicherheitstelefon Sina Communicator
h so heißt das Ding offiziell das ist in
der Tat recht neu dieses Telefon und hat
eine sehr komplizierte Ende zu Ende das
ist ganz neu das steht noch nicht lange
da und wird glaube ich soweit ich weiß
auch noch nicht benutzt angeblich
komplett abhörsicher wobei das letzte
Stück zwischen Lagezentrum und dem
Kanzler manchmal dann unsicher ist aber
es ist eine spannende Geschichte jeder
veröffentlicht dann im Prinzip nur das
was er möchte also was er gesagt hat und
was er rauslassen möchte und die andere
Seite dann